[Müzik]
Evet hepiniz hoş geldiniz Ben Tunç Batum
yaklaşık 35 senedir
1988'den beri Bu mesleğin içindeyim
böyle tam Bununla ilgili Hava atacakken
dışarıda hakkari'yi gördüm Ondan sonra
Şefik abiyi gördüm onlar 50 senelik
Otelci dedim özür dilerim abi ben
körfeziniz olarak şimdi geldim Burada
sunum yapıyorum onlar da hoş gelmişler
Evet
Kısacası bu sektör 50 senelik bir sektör
diyebiliriz
hem sektörle alakalı hem sektörün
dışında da birtakım noktaları
değineceğim TED Talks benim hayatımda
2000'li yıllardan beri çok aktif olarak
var Özellikle spor yaptığım zamanlarda
kulağımda kulaklığımda işte koşu
bandında koşarken dinlediğim tek
tavukların sayısı kendi
üyelik
datama girdiğimde 180'in üzerinde Yani
yaklaşık 2000 dakika 3000 dakika neyse
işte ciddi bir tehdit izlemişim bu tabi
benim
yaşamımın getirdiği de bir
şey Çünkü bizim dönemimizde çok fazla
böyle bilgiye ulaşmak içindeki Kadar
Kolay değildi yani faks cihazı bizim
için çok önemli cihazdır böyle uzaydan
gelmiş gibi hissediyorduk artık onu
düşünün gerisini aradaki farkı size
anlatmayayım Dolayısıyla
yine o dönemde ortaya çıkmış
powerpoint'te sunum yapmak bizim için
Tabii ki çok önemli değil Yine Onu benim
yaşıma yakın olanlar bilir o yüzden
PowerPoint biraz uzun artık onu Dediğim
gibi benim yaşıma vereceksiniz
konum Aslında biraz farklı ve şu ana
kadar çok fazla işlendiğini işine
güçlenmediğinden emin değilim Ama mış
gibi yapmak konum bu ve buradan
farkındalığa doğru bir Evrim yaşayacağız
moş gibi yapmak çağımızın en önemli
hastalıklarından biri Neden
özellikle turizme baktığınızda bunun çok
iyi örneklerini görüyoruz Biz son
80'li yıllarda turizmde işte rahmetli
Özal Turizm bölgelerini yarattığı işte
teşvikler verilmeye başlandı Özal'ın
meşhur hikayesi vardır helikopterle
dolaştırmıştır melek ve Beldibi üzerinde
patronları ve onlara tahsisleri işte
burası senin Burası senin diye tahsis
etmiştir diye bir takım
hikayeler vardır oradan baş harfi
hikayeler 90'larda Golf turizminin
gelişmesi ve daha sonra da Gerçekten
inanılmaz derecede hızla büyüyen bir
sektör
ve bunun arkasına eleman kalifiye eleman
yetiştiremeyen Tabii ki Ee sektörün
profesyonelleri ve
okulları var bunda kimsenin hiçbir suçu
yok Fakat tabii ki
özellikle benim gibi sektörün içinde
yaşamış olanlar bilir
hak etmediği bir pozumuz pozisyona yani
liyakatı olmayan pozisyona Bir takım
insanlar hemen 2-3 pozisyon atlayarak
hemen geldiler Ben de dahil 32 yaşında
Genel Müdürlük teklifi aldım uçtum
havaya o andaki aldığım maaşın Yaklaşık
4 katıydı hemen gittim Genel Müdür oldum
kapıdan içeri adımımı attım
attığım anda onların dışında bildiğim
bir şey vardı Ben o işi hazır değildim
adım attım 3 ay kalmadım İki buçuk gün
önce ayda onlar anladı iki buçuk ay
sürdü anlamaları beni çıkardılar işten
Sağ olsunlar teşekkür ediyorum onlara
Çünkü hazır değildim mış gibi yapmıştım
gelen bir durummuş gibi davranmıştım iyi
bir yiyecek içecek müdürüydüm Ama genel
müdür değildim Dolayısıyla arada fark
var ve ben o farkın farkında değildim o
zamanlar greyderin diye bir
Hey Hunter vardı
genelde onunla çalışırdım çok da
tatlıdır Şu anda da hayatta 80 küsür
yaşında
Özellikle bizim uluslararası Otel
camiasında çok aktif bir kişilikti dedi
ki Oğlum sen dedi genel müdür falan
değilsin
şimdi sana genel müdür işleri ararsak
gireceksin öbür işte 6 ayıp öbür işte 10
ay ama her işten atılacaksın ta ki
atılmayacak hale geldiğin zaman cv'nin
bir çöplüğe dönecek o yüzden dedi sen
dedi gel dedi
sene kaç hatırlamıyorum seni dedi
Bodrum'a dedi bir İsviçre zinciri var
oraya dedi asistan olarak göndereyim
dedi
Ben teşekkür ettim Telefonu kapattım
neredeyse ağlayacağım çok sinirlendim
Çünkü dediği pozisyon ödüllükten 4 aşağı
pozisyon
Neyse düşündüm ettim gri çok
güveniyordum kabul ettim kabul ettikten
sonra mış gibi yapmayı bırakıp Asistan
Efendim birlikte yani bildiğim
pozisyondan tekrar başladım 6 sene sonra
Genel Müdürü olduğumda o pozisyona
hazırdım artık o adamı kapıdan içeri
attığımda Hem
buna yatırımcılarım da mutluydu hem de
ben de mutluydum ve orada ilk girdiğim
Genel Müdürlükte 6 sene çalıştım ve
doğru sonra da devamı geldi Tabii moş
gibi yapanlar arasında
bir kısımmış gibiler daha var onlar
hepimizin hayatında var modaya ayak
uydurmak işte hepimiz moda olan bir
takım şeyleri trendleri takip ediyoruz
müzikleri dinliyoruz Bu Muş gibilerin
hiçbir sakıncası yok hepimizde çünkü
buna benzer şeyler var
üçüncüsü ise
daha tehlikeli olan bir konu o da
kimliğinizin dışında kendi ruhunuzun
karşılayamayacağı derecede bir takım
kimlikler bir takım şapkaları üzerinize
almanızmış gibi yapmanız her şeyi
almamız mümkün değil her role bürünmemiz
mümkün değil bu imkansız Bununla ilgili
çabaladığımız sürece ya fiziksel olarak
Bir takım sıkıntılar yaşıyoruz ya
ruhumuz yoruluyor ya da benzer bir takım
başka sonuçları oluyor Yine kendimden
hızlıca bir örnek vereyim o dönemde
bundan yaklaşık 3-4 sene önce
yaklaşık Evet 3-4 sene önce 2 tane sivil
toplum kuruluşunda yönetim kurulundaydım
bir otelin genel müdürlüğünü yapıyordum
aynı zamanda bir yatırım danışmanlığı
firmasında Türkiye'nin tek sorumlu
danışmanı olarak çalışıyordum
çeşitli uluslararası haber kanallarında
Turizm yorumcusu olarak çıkıyordum onu
çoğaltabilirim iki çocuğum var işte aile
düzeni falan falan derken böyle
inanılmaz roller
Gürler
EGO inanılmaz Tabii besleniyor sürekli
Fakat
tabii devamını tahmin edemedim
bir sabah kalktığımda inanılmaz bir mide
ağrısıyla kalktım
hastaneye gittim daha doğrusu beni
hastaneye götürdüler hastanede mış gibi
yapan maalesef bir doktor arkadaşının
Eline Düştüm
Tansiyonumu 4'e indirmeyi başardı
az daha ölüyordum yani şu merdiveni
Işığı Gördüm de merdivenden çıkmadım
öyle söyleyeyim yaklaşık iki gün yoğun
bakımda kaldım yoğun bakımda kaldığım
zaman bir şey fark ettim Çok hızlı
koşmuş
gerçekten çok hızlı koşmuşum ve bunu
yaşla veya herhangi bir şeyle bir
alakası yok Sizin Öncelikle bedeninizle
ruhunuzun eşit hızda gitmesi gerekiyor
ve bunun için
hemen aklıma Bunlar tahiyyatta hiçbir
şeyin ben tesadüf olduğuna inanan bir
insan değilim aklıma seyrettiğim bir
film geldi 1960'larda filmde işte
köleler var İngiliz sahip var onları
kölelere yük bir sürü yük sırtlarına
veriyor Diyor ki işte şu dağa
tırmanacağız arkalarından kovalayan var
Her neyse Tam da kilometre kalıyor
köleler duruyor adam işte bunları kır
başlıyor falan bir türlü yerlerinden
kıpırdamıyorlar daha sonra kölelerini
lideri diyor ki bizim diyor Kusura bakma
bizi öldürürsen de ilerlemeyiz Çünkü
ruhumuz geride kaldı
bedenimiz ileride ruhumuz geldi
ruhumuzun geri yetişip bize yanımıza
gelmesi gerekiyor Ben ilk önce tabi
yaşayana kadar çok iyi anlamadım ama
gerçekten
bedeniniz aynı paralellikte yan yana
gitmezse o zaman Bir takım sıkıntılar
ortaya çıkıyor
Evet bedenimiz çok hızlı gitti ruhumuz
geride kaldı Bizler o kadar çok
bölünüyoruz ve bedenimiz o kadar çok
yoruyoruz ki hastalanıyoruz ya da
ruhumuzu bu bölmeye yetişemiyor ve
yorgun düşüyor Oysa doğada böyle bir şey
yok mesela doğada bakıyorsunuz Ceylan
önünde koşuyor Aslan arkada koşuyor gibi
yarım dakika içinde eğer Aslan Ceylan'ı
yerse Aslan çok mutlu işte Ceylan
kaçmayı başarırsa Ceylan çok mutlu ama
Aslan Ceylan'ı yakalayamazsa Aslan akşam
arkadaşlarıyla içmeye gitmiyor
efkarların veya Ceylan işte bir Terapiye
gitmiyor galiba biri beni takip ediyor
öyle bir paranoyak duyguları içindeyim
diye bir his içine değil mi
yarım dakika sonra veya 2 dakika sonra
Aslan kendi habitatına geri dönüyor
Ceylan Kendi habitatına geri dönüyor
aslında hani bu son zamanlarda çok bir
trend var ya anında kalmak ya anda kalın
işte kalıp Ya akıl
aklını kullanan insanoğlunun anında
kalması gibi bir şey olabilir mi
benim Bankada bir buçuk milyon dolar
borcu varken Hadi anında kaldı göreyim
seni nasıl alacaksınız
bugün nerede olduğunu iyi bil
Bugünle ilgili elinde olanların değerini
bil gün içinde yaşadığın şeylerin
onları odaklanman gerekiyor Yani bütün
hikaye bu onun dışında Tabii ki
İnsanoğlu hayvanlardan tek büyük farkı
bu akılla olan yolculuğunun daha farklı
olması ile ilgili
Evet
bu verdiğimiz dua örneği çok önemli
Neden Çünkü doğadan çok uzaklaştık
doğayı hep şey zannediyoruz işte gidelim
piknik yapalım işte bahçemiz villamız
varsa orada bir şeyler ekleyelim veya
sokmamızdaki işte hayvanları iyi
davranalım Hayır bu değil
doğa ile bütün bağımızı kaybettik
içselleştiremiyoruz artık kendimiz bir
doğanın parçası olduğumuzu bilmeyerek
davranıyoruz Oysa Biz doğanın çok ufak
veya çok büyük bir parçasız Belki de
Doğa bizim için
sene
yine
1980'de ortası yaşım böyle
15-16 o zamanlar böyle çok büyük dini
inançlarım şunlar bunlar yok Hatta
ateizme doğru böyle bir koşturarak gider
vaziyetteyim
dönemin hemen sonrası
Bizim de Ankara'daki evimizin Karşısında
bir akvaryum dükkanı var bütün Ankara'ya
akvaryum balığı veriyor
kuş tüyü döndü bana baktı
böyle bir kaldım Hani bu ateistlerin
hikayesi vardır ya işte Bir uçakta
sarsılınca Allah hatırlıyorsun bir de
benzeri bu türlü durumlarda buna evrenin
Yüce mimarı deyin yaratıcı değil Üstün
akıl deyin Allah deyin Tanrı değil Niye
inanıyorsanız
ama bütün bu işin içinde bir mimari
düzeni var bir enteresanlık var bunu
yalnızca çok basit bir iki evrim teorisi
veya başka şeyler açıklayamıyorsunuz ve
bu bizim içimizde de var şimdi o balığı
size göstereyim
[Müzik]
Evet blackboss Mike Fish ya da diğer
adıyla tüy balığı
çok enteresan böyle bir hayvan var ne
işe yaradığını Allah bilir ama mutlaka o
zincir içinde emin olun bir şeyin ona
bağlı olan başka zincirde başka bir
canlıda var Aynı şekilde ben bizim
İçimizden bir size benzer bir örnek
göstermek istiyorum
baktığınız zaman bunu da oynatabilirsek
sevinirim
Bu sizin içinizde şu anda 10 milyar
hücre
içinde kinesin proteinler yani motor
proteinler olarak geçiyor
dışarıdan gelen içeriden kim molekülleri
molekülleri dışarı taşıyor veya
dışarıdaki molekülleri içeri taşıyor ve
şu anda bu sizin 10 milyar hücrenizi
içinde var her birinde birkaç tane
olduğunuzu düşünün yani siz aslında bir
evrensiniz Biz evreniz kendi içimizdeki
büyüklüğü düşünebiliyor musunuz
Dolayısıyla evrende doğada ne büyük ne
küçük tartışılır çok belli değil
bizim bu anlamda
ciddi bir şekilde oturup farklı
tutmamızı iyi şekilde düşünüyor olmamız
lazım
fakat farkındalıkla ilgili özellikle
doğa ile ilgili farkındalığımızı belli
bir noktaya getirmek için
başka türlü bir düşünce yapısına sahip
olmamız gerekiyor işte size marves
Marmaris ve Manavgat
yangınlarında ortaya çıkan farkındalık
seviyesi
her şeyin çok farkındayız doğayla
birlikteyiz her şeyi Sürdürülebilir
kılmaya çalışıyoruz
ancak
Sonuçta baktığımızda çok ciddi
bir umarsızlık bir boş vermek boş
vermişlik içindeyiz Meğer süremi aşmaya
başladım O yüzden biraz hızlı gideceğim
tüketime alışkanlığı dolu dizgin kendi
neslini yok etmeye doğru gidiyor
daha önce
bu çevre konferanslarında alınan
kararlarla 2030'da
bir buçuk iki derece dünya ısısının
artacağı öngörülüyordu işte bunu
engellemek için bütün dünyaya Türkiye'de
dahil herkes imza attı ve neler
yapabiliriz diye tartışıldı ülkeler
Turizm sektöründe Biz otellerde Herkes
çok ciddi bir takım aktivitelere
üye olduğu veya kendi içinde bir takım
önlemleri aldı ama o kadar hızlı
değişiyor ki o 2030 hedefi şu anda
2026'ya kadar geri gelmiş durumda Yani
önümüzdeki birkaç senede
biz bu bir buçuk iki derece dünyadaki
ısınmayı yaşayabiliriz ve bunun
sonuçlarını yaşayacağız bu neyi
gösteriyor maalesef uyanma Çağrı bizde
uyandık uyandık
uyandık 5 tane yok olma yani insanlığın
tespit edebildiği son 500 milyon yılda 5
tane yok olma dönemi var
bir en sonuncusu 60 bin sene önce
biliyorsunuz göktaşı vuruyor o zaman
dedi insan yok
bu Normalde her 100 milyon yıl veya 60
milyon yılda bir olay şey
Biz ise Buraya doğru insan olarak
koşturuyoruz şu an ve zamanımız yok
bizim Neslimiz bizim çocuklarımız
buradaki oturan Gençler biz ne
yapabilirsek buradan kurtulabiliriz
yoksa kurtulamayacağız maalesef
son bir şey daha var daha da fazla
uzatmadan bitireceğim konuşmamı daha
hesaplamamı çok iyi yapmadım kusura
bakmayın
gıda üretimi Mesela bizim turizmle
ilgili gıda üretimi dünyanın
kaynaklarını nasıl kirletiyor Nasıl yok
ediyor buradan görebilirsiniz
yaşanılabilir arazi
yüzde kırkını yok ediyor dünyadaki su
kaynakları yiyecek üretiminde %70'i
kullanılıyor
insanlarda ki obezite oranı yüzde 26-60
artmışken insan nüfusunun %11'i aç
dolaşıyor
yiyecek üretimi nedeniyle yaşanılabilir
topraklardaki biyoçeşitliliğin kaybı
yüzde yetmiş tamamen bu yiyecekle ilgili
ve aynı şekilde %50 de yiyecek üretimi
nedeniyle tatlı su kaynaklarının kaybı
Tabii bunlar çoğalıyor Ama bunlar gerçek
Arkadaşlar bunlar hayal değil Belki
torunlarınıza kalacak bir dünya bile
kalıp kalmayacağı şüpheli biraz depresif
bir sunum yaptığım için özür diliyorum
ama hayat bununla gerçek
bir baktığımızda kendi izdüşümümüzü
Benden önceki sunumlarda da bir takım
ölüm veya yaşamla ilgili şeyler söylendi
ama
baktığımızda belki ileriye dönük Vasiyet
verecek bir dünyamız bile olmayabilir
çünkü en son paletli palassiciyan dönemi
galiba
Pardon permiyan döneminde ki gidişatı
çok benziyor şu andaki dönem yok olma
yüzdesi %96 yani yaşayan cinslerin
%96'sı yok olmuş O yüzden kendimize
gelmemiz gerekiyor
doğa ile birlikte olun lütfen Muş gibi
davranmayın kendi yapabilecek ruhunuzla
bedeninize eşitleyin ve doğaya saygı
duyarak tüketim alışkanlığı saç
balığından Lütfen kendinizi sıyırın beni
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim
sağ olun
[Müzik]